I want to put vitamin E on my surgical scars, as my local practitioner said, it is very healing,
even energetically healing, so that the scars do not cause disturbance to the body.
Decides for health brand that I take. Every day stains a bright yellow and that's a laundry
vessel. Is there any other brand of vitamin E that you'd recommend for this purpose? I know that
when you take by mouth it has to be a certain kind of vitamin E. What should I love for?
Well, the vitamin E that's healing to cancer, the vitamin E that's healing to your arteries
is the inner, so remember vitamin E found in nature is a whole food, has four inner
parts called, uh, Tocotriotals and four outer shells called Tocophyrals.
So, um, you want, it's really the inner parts that are beneficial for the vessels and for cancer.
The outer parts have benefits for your skin, so the cheap form of vitamin E is like alpha
Tocopyral, um, that's what you'd buy at like, um, you know, at, you know, Walgreens or something.
And um, that doesn't work on your vessels. In fact, you wouldn't want to use it on your vessels,
so I've had patients that have said, showed me their vitamin E bottle. I've been taking this
and it's literally alpha Tocopyral or DL alpha Tocopyral or, uh, mixed Tocopyrals. Okay,
you could punch a little hole in that capsule and put it on your skin. That's all it's good for,
so it's not good for it to take an oil. So you could use it in expensive vitamin D like that,
that would use, that you'd use topically. Um, I think there's even some vitamin E, um,
um, uh, like sams out there, but they probably don't, they probably contain a whole bunch of
other junk, so you could just get some inexpensive alpha Tocopyral for your skin that would be just fun.